I don't believe that this is an a an
occupied
people I don't believe that the Arabs
are under occupation and that's going to
sound crazy because you're not exposed
to any perspective that sounds like that
so how how are could you ever come to
that
conclusion you have groups of people who
are offered a state who we are not
listening to they do not want the state
that they are offered they offered a
choice between a state and a chant and
if you know the chant it's from the
river to the sea from the river to the
sea is what they chose you could have a
state or you could have a
chant and they want the chant they are
the tip of the
spear in the global battle against
Western hegemony against an occupying
European power in holy Arab
land and they're not going to give up on
that as a collective political entity
for a
relatively
modest prosperous State Trading with it
with the occupier with you know joint
economics joint
faint that's very troubling to us
because we have this idea why wouldn't
you want a state you could have a state
you could be prosperous you could send
your kids to Purdue you
know and
that's that's not easy for us this is
basically if you think about
motherhood you don't think about monism
by
proxy right now what do you de with a
deal what do you do when you have a
mother who comes to the hospital with a
child is continuously getting sick you
know and getting
harmed you
know you have to ask well is it possible
that the mother is harming the child so
you're about to
see
tiny children pulled out of rubble in
Northern Gaza you're going to see it add
nausey you're going to see people
rushing to the hospital you're going to
see mothers wailing so we can talk about
the whole thing about the martyrdom and
how everybody prays that their family
will be martyred and you know what
sometimes it's true sometimes you see on
camera somebody saying thank God they
took my son you know blah blah blah but
those are actually much more complicated
things sometimes you turn the camera off
and the person is crying because they
know what they're supposed to say and
and they know what they're actually
feeling so my my problem with this is
that this is so much more complicated
than the than the discussion we're
pre-programmed to have that is
guaranteed to fail the richness of this
problem where Hamas is effectively the
mother in a monaz and by proxy situation
right and the children inj you're damn
straight you're going to be pulling
babies out of that Rubble because that's
what Hamas wants and Israel cannot
figure out how to extricate yourself
from this Dance of Death so what I'm
trying to say is you don't get out of
this you have a very unconventional foe
in Hamas and in and in totalitarian
Islam and and in Jihad and and in Isis
and Al-Qaeda and for some reason
mainstream
media refuses to show us the images that
they showed us during the Vietnam War
through mainstream Outlets if you saw
what I've seen
if if you if you
watched the Hamas videos the Isis videos
the if you read de beak if you did any
of this
stuff you'd be sick to your stomach
you'd be a changed
person and we don't have that I remember
that the night my parents turned off the
TV during the Vietnam war one of my
earliest memories I believe it was gi's
heads on Pikes carried by by the north
the vietcom you're you're watching
Americans severed heads on sticks if you
think about all the pets are
prizewinning photographs from the
Vietnam era right you're watching a monk
burn to death you're watching a street
execution right to the head you're
watching naked children with their
children with their clothes burned off
from
Napal you didn't see falling man the
most famous picture from 9/11 was
basically not shown in the United States
there is this layer
that is determined to push a fiction to
us which is a transparent fiction
about the general nature of Islam Islam
is complicated you have to study it the
multiple schools of thought Beyond Shia
versus Sunni versus amadi you know you
you could just in Sunni Islam different
schools of jurus prudence which lead to
totally radically different outcomes
between the salafists and the hanafi
adherence and what we've done is we've
come up with this ve this childlike
concept of an oppressed people and a
religion of peace and all of the stuff
is unworkable and it's all mind control
and it's all propaganda and what my
feeling is again is I don't want to
start the conversation from where I
think you guys want to start it from I
want to start from the fact that none of
us are prepared to have this
conversation because we haven't been
exposed to it we don't know what the
real issues are and if we take the terms
that are handed to us
if we have the best and most
intellectual conversation it will still
be completely morally let me just
disagree with the the general thrust of
what you said
there